avec nous maintenant serge coulombe
économiste professeur émérite à
l'université de t'avoir bonsoir serge
coulombe bonsoir alors sommet en 30 ans
pour l'inflation n'était plus de 5% même
en ontario et au québec est-ce que c'est
grave
oui
c'est important de mentionner
comme ça que c'est ce que la dose sujet
style de façon assez importante
l'inflation au canada comparé à l'argent
c'était sec américaine puisqu'elle ne
sait pas quand de l'augmentation
considérable d'environ 35% du prix des
voitures d'occasion depuis le début de
la pandémie et si on rajoute cette
augmentation au taux d'inflation
canadien pour pouvoir la comparer au
tout notre personnel et qu'un nom qu'on
se retrouve avec environ 6 % d'inflation
tard oui donc oui c'est grave parce que
c'est en train d'une érosion du pouvoir
d'achat comme vous l'avez mentionné les
alae rendement moins rapidement dans les
canadiens certains gars n'était elle
s'appauvrit ceux qui reçoivent
uniquement le salaire moyen est
également sujet grave parce que ça
pourrait entraîner des hausses de 1
point 2 2 points de pourcentage des taux
d'intérêt hypothécaires qui pourrait
entraîner des centaines de dollars de
plus par mois aux ménages pour leur
versement et quel est l'effet au micro
jusqu'à maintenant parce qu'on sait
qu'au micro au ralenti l'économie peut
affecter les chaînes d'approvisionnement
est ce que ça vient selon votre analyse
amplifie l'inflation oui
l'inflation présentement est surtout dû
à des problèmes d'offre des problèmes
d'approvisionnement manque de
main-d'oeuvre puis des chaînes
d'approvisionnement
tout ça à cause de la pandémie et il
délivre les hyper spécialisation des
économies mondiales avec le variant au
micro il ya encore des lignes
d'approvisionnement qui sont coupés il
ya des problèmes avec le transport
enlever le camionneur récemment dans wii
toute restriction de la risque de mettre
encore de l'huile sur le feu dans les
faits est ce que comme le directeur
parlementaire du budget dit aujourd'hui
les mesures de relance économique qui
avait été prévu par le gouvernement
trudeau dès l'automne 2020 on parlait de
100 milliards de dollars il dit que ce
n'est plus nécessaire de faire ça vous
en pensez quoi
je suis d'accord avec lui même je vous
le disais en novembre à votre émission
que dans une économie où est-ce qu'ils
doivent l'inflation et des problèmes
d'offre
si on doit pas faire des mesures de
soutien du revenu ou même des mesures de
subvention salariale il semblerait que
ce soit contre indiqués c'est comme
mettre de l'huile sur le feu à
l'inflation mais surtout ce sont des
mesures qui ont été mises de l'avant
dans une situation d'urgence à l'époque
qui n'ont pas toujours été bien dessinée
qui ont été peaufinés par la suite mais
ça demeure des mesures d'urgence or ça
fait deux ans maintenant le suffit d'y
ans que l'économie canadienne suit des
soins d'urgence est important je serais
plutôt tant que ces soins se tourner
vers des soins de longue durée dans le
besoin présentement une des mesures
économiques qui vont faciliter
l'ajustement de l'économie qui ne
stimuleront pas la demande et qui va
permettre à
la main d'oeuvre de quitter un secteur
pour aller dans un autre secteur où est
ce qu'il ya des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre et ce n'est pas ça on achève
avec
les mesures de soutien aux revenus et de
se battre on s'attend à ce que
l'inflation monte encore un peu en tout
cas pour les prochains mois est ce que
le remède est le gros run aide c'est
d'augmenter les taux d'intérêt dès la
semaine prochaine à la banque du canada
puis de le faire le souvent 2022 mais la
semaine prochaine on le sait pas assez
passer des marchés anticipent
présentement kwh est une bonne chose et
taux d'intérêt mais c'est clair que le
seul outil économique véritable que le
gouvernement fédéral le gouvernement
canadien or à sa disposition pour lutter
contre nation c'est la hausse des taux
d'intérêt mais ça veut dire c'est clair
mais c'est risqué parce que dans le
record de l'inflation qui provient de
l'offre
certains économistes pensent qu'il faut
y aller très très prudemment parce qu'en
les problèmes doivent régler 9
changements à venir alors on le sait les
hausses de taux d'intérêt pourrait avoir
un effet ce n'est pas très néfastes sur
les marchés immobiliers est grugé
énormément dans le budget des des
canadiens qui ont enfin fait beaucoup
depuis deux ans pour acheter des maisons
très cher mais est ce que le danger
c'est ça c'est à dire de monter les taux
trop rapidement ou le danger c'est de
laisser aller une inflation pour
laquelle on pourrait perdre un peu le
contrôle
vous savez vous avez très bien résumé le
problème présentement il ya beaucoup
d'incertitude dans la politique et il
est clair que les banques centrales
doivent hausser les taux d'intérêt pour
signaler au marché elles ne laisseront
pas aller l'inflation
trop loin et mais ceci en refaisant va
avoir un impact pour restreindre
l'accès au crédit des consommateurs et
des entreprises donc c'est clair que
quand on veut lutter contre l'inflation
à l'eau sans les taux d'intérêt il ya
des gens qui perdent dans les chambres
des claques merci serge coulombe pour
cette analyse ce soir
au plus vite pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh